la majorité présidentielle répond très
favorablement à l'initiative de renaud
muselier
cette petite phrase de jean castex a
fait l'effet d'une bombe hier dans le
journal du dimanche
elle annonce en effet le retrait de la
liste lrm au premier tour des élections
régionales en provence alpes côte d'azur
au profit du président ait l'air sortant
de la région et la sanction n'a pas
tardé
du côté des républicains après l'annonce
des petites manoeuvres électorales en
paca par monsieur castex renaud muselier
conformément aux règles des républicains
qui impose qu'il n'y a aucun accord de
premier tour avec l om ne pourra pas
bénéficier de l'investiture et leur
celui qui s'estime être le candidat le
plus à même de l'emporter se défend de
toute trahison
il faut tout faire pour que leur région
ne tombe pas aux mains d'un parti
extrémiste
j'ai fait appel au soutien le plus large
je pense que le dépassement est
impératif pour des élections locales
le premier ministre a répondu
positivement et annoncé le retrait d'une
candidature gouvernementale cette liste
sera d'abord celle de la majorité
actuelle plurielle mais le mal est fait
pour une partie des élus les
républicains certains affirment qu'il
s'agit là d'un coup monté par l'elysée
pour faire taire toute opposition celle
de droite en particulier immense
tristesse face à ce coup de poignard
dans le dos je le savais dès avant le
premier tour de la présidentielle
ils préparaient leur mauvaise soupe sur
le petit feu élyséen dans la mauvaise
marmite en marche
muselier enlève le masque et assume de
se soumettre à macron les 20 et 27 juin
renvoyer les républicains en marche aux
poubelles de l'histoire
reste à savoir maintenant c'est après le
retrait de l'investiture de renaud
muselier les républicains décident
d'investir un autre candidat
ce scénario pourrait comporter un risque
celui de diviser l'électorat de la
droite et du centre en paca au profit de
thierry mariani
ancien et l'air devenue tête de liste du
rassemblement national